Good morning.
It looks like 9:30 is getting
earlier and earlier for
everyone.
Hello to all the people
watching at home.
I think there should be a
requirement that if you're
watching the video,
you can only watch it
9:30-11:00 on Sunday,
or at least start watching then
just so you can all feel our
mornings.
Today, we're going to talk
about balanced search trees.
Now, we've hinted at this for a
while.
Our goal today is to get a
search tree data structure,
so we can insert,
delete, and search all at log n
time for operations.
So, we want a tree that's
guaranteed to be log n in
height.
So, that's a balanced search
tree data structure.
And, we want a data structure
that can maintain a dynamic set
of n elements in log n time for
operation.
So, we'll say,
using a tree of height order
log n.
Now, if you look very closely,
we haven't actually defined
what a search tree data
structure is.
We've defined what a binary
search tree data structure is,
and that's one particular kind.
And that's what we will be
focusing on today.
In recitation on Friday,
we will look at,
or you will like that,
balanced search trees that are
not necessarily binary.
Each node can have a constant
number of children,
not just two.
So, I'm defining is generally.
You actually see what a search
tree is in the general case
later on.
Today, we will just be focusing
on the binary case.
So, I won't define this yet.
So, there are a lot of
different balanced search tree
data structures.
So, these are the main ones
that I know of.
The first one was AVL trees.
This was invented in 1962.
So, that was the beginning of
fast data structures.
The next three sort of come
together and this is what you
will cover in recitation this
week.
So, these are non binary trees.
Instead of binary,
we have maybe binary and
tertiary, or maybe binary and
tertiary, or quaternary,
over a general concept degree,
B.
So, that's another way you can
get balance.
Two-three trees,
which were the second trees to
be invented, they were invented
in 1970 by Hopcroft.
The trees we will cover today
are called red black trees.
These are binary search trees
of guaranteed logarithmic
height.
So then, there's some others.
So, skip lists are ones that we
will cover next week.
It's not exactly a tree,
but it's more or less a tree,
and one that you will see in
your problem set this week are
treeps, which I won't talk too
much about here.
But they are in some sense
easier to get because they
essentially just rely on the
material from last Monday.
So, on Monday we saw that if we
just randomly built a binary
search tree, it's going to have
log n height most of the time in
expectation.
So, treeps are a way to make
that dynamic,
so that instead of just having
a static set of n items,
you can insert and delete into
those items and still
effectively randomly permute
them and put them in a tree.
So in some sense,
it's the easiest.
It's also one of the most
recent search tree data
structures.
That was invented in 1996 by a
couple of geometers,
Rimon Sidell and Aragen.
So, those are just some search
tree data structures.
The only ones we will not cover
in this class are AVL trees.
They're not too hard.
If you're interested,
you should read about them
because they're fun.
I think they are a problem in
the textbook.
OK, but today,
we're going to focus on red
black trees, which is a fairly
simple idea, red black trees.
And, it's a particular way of
guaranteeing this logarithmic
height so that all the
operations can be supported in
log n time.
So, they are binary search
trees.
And, they have a little bit of
extra information in each node
called the color field.
And there are several
properties that a tree with a
color field has to satisfy in
order to be called a red black
tree.
These are called the red black
properties.
And, this will take a little
bit of time to write down,
but it's all pretty simple.
So once I write them down I
will just say what they really
mean.
There's four properties.
The first one's pretty simple.
Every node is either red or
black, hence the name of red
black trees.
So, the color field is just a
single bit specifying red or
black.
And red nodes,
I'm going to denote by a double
circle because I don't have
colored chalk here,
and black nodes will be a
single circle.
And you probably don't have
colored pens either,
so it will save us some grief.
Red is double circle;
black is single circle.
And, we sort of prefer black
nodes in some sense.
Red nodes are a pain,
as we'll see.
OK, second property is that the
root and the leaves are all
black.
And, I'm going to pull a little
trick here.
Treat binary search trees a
little bit differently than we
have in the past.
Normally, you think of the tree
as a bunch of nodes.
Each node could have zero or
one or two children,
something like this.
I'm going to imagine appending
every place where a node does
not have a child.
I'm going to put a little dot
here, an external node,
which I call a leaf.
So, normally leaves would have
been these items.
I'm just going to add to every
absent child pointer a leaf.
And, these will be my leaves.
These are really the nil
pointers from each of these
nodes.
So now, every internal node has
exactly two children,
and every leaf has zero
children.
OK, so these are those I'm
referring to.
These are black,
and this guy is black according
to rule two.
Now the properties get a little
bit more interesting.
The parent of every red node is
black.
So, whenever I have a red node,
its parent has to be black,
a single circle.
OK, so in other words,
if you look at a path in the
tree you can never have two red
nodes consecutive.
You can have,
at most, red,
black, red, black.
You can have several black
nodes consecutive,
but never two red nodes.
OK, and then one more rule.
It says a little bit more about
such paths.
So, if we take a simple path,
meaning it doesn't repeat any
vertices from a node,
x, to a descended leaf of x,
all such paths to all
descendant leaves have the same
number of black nodes on them.
So, let me draw a picture.
We have some tree.
We have some node,
x, in the tree.
And, I'm looking at all the
paths from x down to some
descendant leaf down here at the
bottom of the tree.
All of these paths should have
the same number of black nodes.
So, here I'll draw that each
one has four black nodes,
the leaf, and three above it.
We know that from property
three, at most,
half of the nodes are red
because whenever I have a red
node, the parent must be black.
But I want all of these paths
to have exactly the same number
of black nodes.
One subtlety here is that the
black height,
I didn't really leave room.
So I'll write it over here.
This should be the same for all
paths, but in particular,
the count I'm interested in
does not include x itself.
OK, so if x is black,
I'm only calling the black
height.
So, the black height of x is
this count four.
And even if x is black,
the black height is four.
So, these are just some minor
details to get all of the
algorithms a bit clean.
So, let's look at an example of
a red black tree.
So, yeah, I'll show you an
example.
Then I'll say why we care about
these properties.
OK, so this tree has several
properties.
The first thing is that it's a
binary search tree.
OK, and so you can check an [in
order traversal?].
It should give these numbers in
sorted order:
three, seven,
eight, ten, 11,
18, 22, 26.
So, it's a valid binary search
tree.
We've appended these leaves
with no keys in them.
They are just hanging around.
Those are the nil pointers.
So, each of these,
you can call them nil.
They are all just marked there,
wherever there is absent child.
And then, I've double circled
some of the nodes to color them
red.
OK, if I didn't,
the black heights wouldn't
match up.
So, I have to be a little bit
careful.
From every node,
we'd like to measure the number
of black nodes from that node
down to any descendent leaf.
So, for example,
the nil pointers,
their black height is zero.
Good.
That's always the answer.
So, these guys always have
black height zero.
I'll just represent that here.
Black height equals zero.
OK, what's the black height of
three?
Zero?
Not quite, because these nodes
are black.
So the black height is one.
You're right that we don't
count three even though it's
black.
It's not included in the count.
But the leaves count.
And there's only two paths
here, and they each have the
same number of black nodes as
they should.
Over here, let's say eight also
has black height one even though
it's red.
OK: same with 11,
same with 26.
Each of them only has two
paths.
Each path has one black node on
it.
Ten: what's the black height?
It's still one,
good, because we don't count
ten.
There's now four paths to
leaves.
Each of them contains exactly
one black node,
plus the root,
which we don't count.
22: same thing,
hopefully.
This is getting a little more
interesting.
There's one path here which has
one black node.
There are other paths here,
which are longer.
But they still only have one
black node.
So, if we just sort of ignore
the red nodes,
all these paths have the same
length.
OK: 18 should be bigger
hopefully, black height of two
because each of these paths now
has one black node here,
one black node in leaves,
or one black note here,
and one black node in the
leaves.
And finally,
the root should have a black
height of two.
It's easier to see over here,
I guess.
Each of these paths has two
black nodes.
Same over here.
OK, so hopefully these
properties make sense.
We didn't check all of them.
Every red node has a black
parent.
If you look at all of these
paths, we sort of alternate,
red, black at most.
Or we have just a bunch of
blacks.
But we never repeat two reds in
a row.
The root and the leaves are
black that we used pretty much
by definition.
Every node is red or black.
OK, that's easy.
This is a particular set of
properties.
It may seem a bit arbitrary at
this point.
They will make a lot more sense
as we see what consequences they
have.
But there are a couple of goals
that we are trying to achieve
here.
One is that these properties
should force the tree to have
logarithmic height,
order log n height.
And, they do,
although that's probably not
obvious at this point.
It follows mainly from all the
properties.
Three and four are the main
ones.
But you pretty much need all of
them.
The other desire we have from
these properties is that they
are somehow easy to maintain.
OK, I can create a tree in the
beginning that has this
property.
For example,
I could make,
I have to be a little bit
careful, but certainly if I take
a perfectly balanced binary tree
and make all of the nodes black,
it will satisfy those
properties.
OK, this is a red black tree.
OK, so it's not too hard to
make any these properties hold
just from the beginning.
The tricky part is to maintain
them.
When I insert a node into this
tree, and delete a node for this
tree, I want to make it not too
hard.
In log n time,
I've got to be able to restore
all these properties.
OK, that will be the hardest
part.
The first thing we will do is
prove that these properties
imply that the tree has to have
height order log n.
Therefore, all searches and
queries on a data structure will
run fast.
The hard part will be to make
sure these properties stay true
if they initially held true when
we make changes to the tree.
So, let's look at the height of
a red black tree.
And from this we will start to
see where these properties come
from, why we chose these
properties.
So, the claim is that the
height of a red black tree with
n keys, so, I'm not saying nodes
here because I really only want
to count the internal nodes,
not these extra leaves that
we've added, has height,
at most, two times log of n
plus one, so order log n.
But, we have a pretty precise
bound of a factor of two.
There is a proof of this in the
textbook by induction,
and you should read that.
What I'm going to give us more
of a proof sketch.
But you should read the proof
by induction because all the
practice you can get with proof
by induction is good.
The proof sketch on the other
hand gives a lot more intuition
with what's going on with red
black trees and connects up with
recitation on Friday.
So, let me tell you that
instead.
I'm going to leave that board
blank and go over here.
So, the first thing I'm going
to do, I'm going to manipulate
this tree until it looks like
something that I know.
The main change I'm going to
make is to merge each red node
into its parent.
And we know that the parent of
a red node must be black.
So, merge each red node into
its black parent.
So, let's look at that here.
So, I'm going to take this red
node, merge it into its parent,
take this red node,
merge it into its path,
and so on.
There's one up there which I
can't reach.
But I'm going to redraw this
picture now.
So, seven, so the top node now
becomes, in some sense,
seven and 18.
They got merged together,
but no one else joined them.
Then, on the left,
we have three.
OK, nothing joined that,
and there's some leaves as
usual.
Now, if you look at,
maybe, I'm going to have to
draw this.
Uh-oh.
I heard that sound before.
So, I'm merging these nodes
together, and I'm merging all of
these nodes together because
each of these red nodes merges
into that black node.
And, I'm merging these two
nodes together.
So, I'm putting this red node
into that black node.
So, now you can see from the
root, which is now 7/18.
There are three children
hanging off.
So, in that picture,
I'd like to draw that fact
assuming I can get this board
back down.
Good.
So, between seven and 18,
I have this conglomerate node,
eight, ten, 11.
And, there are four leaves
hanging off of that node.
And, off to the right,
after 18, I have a conglomerate
node, 22/26, and there are three
leaves hanging off of there.
OK, kind of a weird tree
because we dealt mainly with
binary trees so far,
but this is a foreshadowing of
what will come on Friday.
This is something called a
two-three-four tree.
Any guesses why it's called a
two-three-four tree?
Every node can have two,
three, or four kids,
yeah, except the leaves.
They have zero.
There is another nice property
of two-three-four trees maybe
hinted at.
So, there's really no control
over whether you have two
children or three children or
four children.
But, there is another nice
property.
Yeah?
All of the leaves have the same
depth, exactly.
All of these guys have the same
depth in the tree.
Why is that?
Because of property four.
On Friday, you will see just
how to maintain that property.
But out of this transformation,
we get that all the leaves have
the same depth:
because their depth,
now, or let's say their height
in the tree is their black
height.
And, the depth of these leaves
will be the black height of the
root.
We are you raising all the red
nodes, and we said if we look at
a path, and we ignore all the
red nodes, then the number of
black nodes along a path is the
same.
Now we are basically just
leaving all the black nodes.
And so, along all these paths
we'll have the same number of
black nodes.
And therefore,
every leaf will have the same
depth.
Let me write down some of these
properties.
So, every internal node has
between two and four children.
And every leaf has the same
depth, namely,
the black height of the root.
This is by property four.
OK, so this is telling us a
lot.
So, essentially what this
transformation is doing is
ignoring the red nodes.
Then, if you just focus on the
black nodes, height equals black
height.
And then, black height is
telling us that all the root to
leaf paths have the same length.
Therefore, all these nodes are
at the same level.
Having leaves at the same level
as a good thing because it means
that your tree is pretty much
balanced.
If you have a tree where all
the nodes are branching,
so, they'll have at least two
children, and all the leaves are
at the same level,
that's pretty balanced.
OK, we will prove some form of
that now.
I'm going to call the height of
this tree h prime.
The height of the original tree
is h.
That's what we want to bound
here.
So, the first thing is to bound
h prime.
And then we want to relate h
and h prime.
OK, so the first question is
how many leaves are there in
this tree?
And, it doesn't really matter
which tree I'm looking at
because I didn't really do
anything to the leaves.
All the leaves are black.
So the leaves didn't change.
How many leaves are there in
this tree, and then therefore,
industry?
Sorry?
Nine.
Indeed, there are nine,
but I meant in general,
sorry.
In this example there are nine.
How many keys are there?
Eight.
So, in general,
how do you write nine as a
function of eight for large
values of nine or eight?
Sorry?
Plus one, good,
correct answer,
by guessing.
n plus one.
OK, why is it n plus one?
Let's look at the binary tree
case where we sort of understand
what's going on?
Well, wherever you have a key,
there are two branches.
And, that's not a very good
argument.
OK, we have what is here called
a branching binary tree.
Every internal node has exactly
two children.
And, we are counting the number
of leaves that you get from that
process in terms of the number
of internal nodes.
The number of leaves in a tree,
or a branching tree,
as always one plus the number
of internal nodes.
You should know that.
You can prove it by induction.
OK, so the number of leaves is
n plus one.
It doesn't hold if you have a
single child.
It holds if every internal node
has a branching factor of two.
OK, this is a neither tree.
And now, we want to pull out
some relation between the number
of leaves and the height of the
tree.
So, what's a good relation to
use here?
We know exactly how many leaves
there are.
That will somehow connect us to
n.
What we care about is the
height.
And let's look at the height of
this tree.
So, if I have a two-three-four
tree of height h prime,
how many leaves could it have?
What's the minimum and maximum
number of leaves it could have?
2^h to 4^h, or h prime.
So, we also know in the
two-three-four tree,
the number of leaves has to be
between four to the h prime,
because at most I could branch
four ways in each node.
And, it's at least two to the h
prime because I know that every
node branches at least two ways.
That's key.
So, I only care about one of
these, I think this one.
So, I get that two to the h
prime is, at most,
n plus one.
So the number of leaves is n
plus one.
We know that exactly.
So, we rewrite,
we take logs of both sides.
It says h one is at most log of
n plus one.
So, we have a nice,
balanced tree.
This should be intuitive.
If I had every node branching
two ways, and all the leaves at
the same level,
that's a perfect tree.
It should be exactly log base
two of n plus one,
and turns out not quite n.
That should be the height of
the tree.
Here, I might have even more
branching, which is making
things even shallower in some
sense.
So, I get more leaves out of
the same height.
But that's only better for me.
That will only decrease the
height in terms of the number of
leaves.
n plus one here is the number
of leaves.
So: cool.
That's an easy upper bound on
the height of the tree.
Now, what we really care about
is the height of this tree.
So, we want to relate h and h
prime.
Any suggestions on how we might
do that?
How do we know that the height
of this reduced tree is not too
much smaller than this one.
We know that this one is,
at most, log n.
We want this to be,
at most, two log n plus one.
We know the answer.
We've said the theorem.
Sorry?
Right.
So, property three tells us
that we can only have one red
node for every black one.
We can, at most,
alternate red and black.
So, if we look at one of these
paths that goes from a root to a
leaf, the number of red nodes
can be, at most,
half the length of the path.
And we take the max overall
paths, that's the height of the
tree.
So, we know that h is,
at most, two times h prime,
or maybe it's easier to think
of h prime is at least a half,
h.
Assuming I got that right,
because at most a half of the
nodes on any root to leaf path
--
-- are red.
So, at least half of them have
to be black.
And, all-black nodes are
captured in this picture so we
have this relation,
and therefore,
h is, at most,
two times log n plus one.
OK: pretty easy.
But you have to remember,
this tree has to be balanced,
and they are not too far away
from each other.
OK, so in Friday's recitation,
you will see how to manipulate
trees with this form.
There is a cool way to do it.
That's two-three-four trees.
Today, we're going to see how
to manipulate trees in this form
as red black trees.
And, you'll see today's
lecture, and you'll see Friday's
recitation, and they won't
really seem to relate at all.
But they're the same,
just a bit hidden.
OK, so this is good news.
We now know that all red black
trees are balanced.
So as long as we can make sure
that our tree stays a red black
tree, we'll be OK.
We'll be OK in the sense that
the height is always log n.
And therefore,
queries in a red black tree,
so queries are things like
search, find a given key,
find the minimum,
find the maximum,
find a successor,
find a predecessor.
These are all queries that we
know how to support in a binary
search tree.
And we know how to do them in
order height time.
And the height here is log n so
we know that all of these
operations take order log n in a
red black tree.
OK --
So, queries are easy.
We are done with queries,
just from balance:
not a surprise.
We know that balances is good.
The hard part for us will be to
do updates.
And in this context,
updates means insert and
delete.
In general, and a data
structure, we talk about queries
which ask questions about the
data in the structure,
and updates which modify the
data in the structure.
And most of the time here,
we are always thinking about
dynamic sets.
So, you can change the dynamics
set by adding or deleting an
element.
You can ask all sorts of
questions.
In priority queues,
there were other updates like
delete Min.
Here we have find Min,
but we could then delete it.
Typically these are the
operations we care about.
And we'll talk about updates to
include those of these,
and queries to include all of
these, or whatever happens to be
relevant.
In problem sets especially,
you'll see all sorts of
different queries that you can
support.
OK, so how do we support
updates?
Well, we have binary search
tree insert, which we call tree
insert.
We have binary search tree
delete, tree delete.
They will preserve the binary
search tree property,
but we know they don't
necessarily preserve balance.
We can insert a bunch of nodes.
Just keep adding new minimum
elements and you will get a
really long path off the end.
So, presumably,
they do not preserve the red
black properties because we know
red black implies balance.
In particular,
they won't satisfy property
one, which I've erased,
which is every node is red or
black.
It'll add a node,
and not assign it a color.
So, we've got to assign it a
color.
And, as soon as we do that,
we'll probably violate some
other property.
And then we have to fix that
property, and so on.
So, it's a bit tricky,
but you play around with it and
it's not too hard.
OK, so updates must modify the
tree.
And to preserve the red black
properties, they're going to do
it in three different kinds of
modifications.
The first thing we will indeed
do is just use the BST
operation, tree insert or tree
delete.
That's something we know how to
do.
Let's just do it.
We are going to have to change
the colors of some of the nodes.
In particular,
the one that we insert better
be colored somehow.
And in general,
if we just rip out a node,
we are going to have to recolor
it, recolor some nearby nodes.
There is one other kind of
operation we're going to do.
So, recoloring just means set
to red or black.
The other thing you might do is
rearrange the tree,
change the pointers,
change the links from one node
to another.
And, we're going to do that at
the very structured way.
And, this is one of the main
reasons that red black trees are
interesting.
The kinds of changes they make
are very simple,
and they also don't make very
many of them.
So, they're called rotations.
So, here's a rotation.
OK, this is a way of drawing a
generic part of a tree.
We have two nodes,
A and B.
There is some subtrees hanging
off, which we draw as triangles.
We don't know how big they are.
We know they better all have
the same black height if it's a
red black tree.
But in general,
it just looks like this.
There is some parent,
and there's some rest of the
tree out here which we don't
draw.
I'll give these subtrees names,
Greek names,
alpha, beta,
gamma.
And, I'll define the operation
right rotate of B.
So general, if I have a node,
B, I look at it and I want to
do it right rotation,
I look at its left child enjoy
this picture called the subtrees
of those two nodes.
And, I create this tree.
So, all I've done is turn this
edge 90∞.
What was the parent of B is now
the parent of A.
A is now the new parent of B.
The subtrees rearrange.
Before, they were both subtrees
of, these two were subtrees of
A.
And, gamma was a subtree of B.
Gamma is still a subtree of B,
and alpha still is a subtree of
A.
But, beta switched to being a
subtree of B.
OK, the main thing we want to
check here is that this
operation preserves the binary
search tree property.
Remember, the binary search
tree property says that all the
elements in the left subtree of
a node are less than or equal to
the node, and all the elements
in the right subtree are greater
than or equal to that value.
So, in particular,
if we take some node,
little a in alpha,
little b in beta,
and little c in gamma,
then a is less than or equal to
capital A, is less than or equal
to little b, is less than or
equal to capital B,
is less than or equal to little
c.
And, this is the condition both
on the left side and on the
right side because Alpha is left
of everything.
Beta is in between A and B,
and gamma is after B.
And the same thing is true over
here.
Beta is still,
it's supposed to be all the
nodes that come between capital
A and capital B.
So, this is good.
We could definitely do this
operation, still have the binary
search tree, and we are going to
use rotations in a particularly
careful way to make sure that we
maintain all these properties.
That's the hard part.
But, rotations will be our key.
This was the right rotate
operation.
The reverse operation is left
rotate.
So, this is left rotate of A.
In general, of the two nodes
that are involved,
we list the top one.
So, its right rotate of B will
give you this.
Left rotate of A will give you
this.
So, these are reversible
operations, which feels good.
The other thing is that they
only take constant time
operations because we are only
changing a constant number of
pointers.
As long as you know the node,
B, that you are interested in,
you set the left pointer of B
to be, if you want it to be
beta, so you set left of B to be
right of A, and so on,
and so on.
You make constant number of
those changes.
You update the parents as well.
It's only a constant number of
links that are changing,
so, a constant number of
assignments you need to do.
So, you've probably seen
rotations before.
But we are going to use them in
a complicated way.
So, let's look at how to do
insertion.
We'll see it three times in
some sense.
First, I'll tell you the basic
idea, which is pretty simple.
I mentioned some of it already.
Then, we'll do it on an
example, feel it in our bones,
and then we'll give the
pseudocode so that you could go
home and implement it if you
wanted.
OK, this is,
I should say,
red black insert,
which in the book is called RB
insert, not for root beer,
but for red black.
OK, so the first thing we're
going to do, as I said,
is binary search tree,
insert that node.
So, x now becomes a new leaf.
We searched for x wherever it's
supposed to go.
We create, I shouldn't call it
a leaf now.
It's now at node hanging off.
It's an internal node hanging
off one of the original nodes.
Maybe we added it right here.
It now gets two new leaves
hanging off of it.
It has no internal children.
And, we get to pick a color for
it.
And, we will pick the color
red.
OK, why red?
We definitely have to pick one
of two colors.
We could flip a coin.
That might work,
but it's going to make our job
even messier.
So, we are adding a new node.
It's not a root or a leaf
presumably, so we don't really
need it to be black by property
two.
Property three,
every red node has a black
parent.
That might be a problem.
So, the problem is if its
parent is red.
Then we violate property two.
The parent might be red,
property three,
sorry.
OK, the good news is that
property four is still true
because property four is just
counting numbers of black nodes
down various paths.
That's really the hard property
to maintain.
If we just add a new red node,
none of the black heights
change.
None of the number of black
nodes along the path changes.
So, this still has to hold.
The only thing we can violate
is property three.
That's reasonable.
We know we've got to violate
something at the beginning.
We can't just do a binary
search tree insert.
OK, so, let's give it a try on
this tree.
I should say how we are going
to fix this.
How do we fix property three?
We are going to move the
violation of three up the tree.
So, we're going to start at
node x, and move up towards the
root.
This is via recoloring.
The only thing,
initially, we'll do is
recoloring until we get to some
point where we can fix the
violation using a rotation --
-- and probably also
recoloring.
OK, so let's see this algorithm
in action.
I want to copy this tree,
and you are going to have to
copy it, too.
So, I'll just redraw it instead
of modifying that diagram.
So, we have this nice red black
tree.
And, we'll try inserting a new
value of 15.
22 black.
22 is the new black.
OK, that should be the same
tree.
So now, I'm choosing the number
15 to insert,
because that will show a fairly
interesting insertion.
Sometimes, the insertion
doesn't take very much work.
We just do the rotation and
we're done.
I just like to look at an
interesting case.
So, we insert 15.
15 is bigger than seven.
It's less than 18.
It's bigger than ten.
It's bigger than 11.
So, 15 goes here.
So, we add a new red node of
00:45:53,000 --> 00:00:15,000
And, it has two black leaves
hanging off of it,
replaced one black leaf.
Now we have two.
OK, now, we violate property
three because we added a new red
child of a red node.
So, now we have two consecutive
red nodes in a root to leaf
path.
We'd like to make this black,
but that would screw up the
black heights because now this
node would have one black node
over here, and two black nodes
down this path.
So, that's not good.
What can we do?
Well, let's try to re-color.
Yes.
This always takes a little
while to remember.
So, our fix is going to be to
recolor.
And, the first thing that
struck me, which doesn't work,
is we try to recolor around
here.
It doesn't look so good because
we've got red stuff out here,
but we've got a black node over
here.
So we can't make this one red,
and this one black.
It wouldn't quite work.
If we look up a little higher
at the grandparent of 15 up
here, we have a black node here
and two red children.
That's actually pretty good
news because we could,
instead, make that two black
children and a red parent.
Locally, that's going to be
fine.
It's not going to change any
black heights because any path
that went through these nodes
before will still go through the
same number of black nodes.
Instead of going through a
black node always here,
it will go through a black node
either here or here because
paths always go down to the
leaves.
So, that's what we're going to
do, recolor these guys.
And, we will get ten,
which is red.
We'll get eight,
which is black,
11 which is black,
and these things don't change.
Everything else doesn't change.
We are going to leave 15 red.
It's no longer in violation.
15 is great because now its
parent is black.
We now have a new violation up
here with 18 because 18 is also
red.
That's the only violation we
have.
In general, we'll have,
at most, one violation at any
time until we fix it.
Then we'll have zero
violations.
OK, so, now we have a violation
between ten and 18:
somehow always counterintuitive
to me.
I had to look at the cheat
sheet again.
Really?
No, OK, good.
I was going to say,
we can't recolor anymore.
Good.
I'm not that bad.
So, what we'd like to do is,
again, look at the grandparent
of ten, which is now seven,
the root of the tree.
It is black,
but one of its children is
black.
The other is red.
So, we can't play the same game
of taking the blackness of
seven, and moving it down to the
two children.
Never mind that the root is
supposed to stay black.
We'll ignore that property for
now.
We can't make these two black
and make this one red,
because then we'd get an
imbalance.
This was already black.
So now, paths going down here
will have one fewer black node
than paths going out here.
So, we can't just recolor seven
and its children.
So, instead,
we've got to do a rotation.
We'd better be near the end.
So, what I will do is rotate
this edge.
I'm going to rotate eight to
the right.
So that's the next operation:
rotate right of 18.
We'll delete one more operation
after this.
So, we rotate right 18.
So, the root stays the same:
seven, three,
its children.
Now, the right child of seven
is no longer 18.
It's now ten.
18 becomes the red child of
ten.
OK, we have eight over here
with its two children.
11 and 15: that subtree fits in
between ten and 18.
So, it goes here:
11 and 15.
And then, there's the right
subtree.
Everything to the right of 18,
that goes over here:
22 and 26.
And hopefully I'm not changing
any colors during that
operation.
If I did, let me know.
OK, it looks good.
So, I still have this
violation, still in trouble
between ten and 18.
But, I've made this straighter.
OK, that's what we want to do,
it turns out,
is make the connection between
18, the violator,
and its grandparent,
a straight connection:
two rights or two lefts.
Here we had to zigzag right,
left.
We like to make it straight.
OK, it doesn't look like a much
more balanced tree that this
one.
In fact, it looks a little
worse.
What we can do is now rotate
these guys, or rather,
rotate this edge.
I'm going to rotate seven to
the left, make ten the root,
and that things will start to
look balanced.
This is a rotate left of seven.
And, I'm also going to do some
recoloring at the same time just
to save me drawing one more
picture because the root has to
be black.
I'm going to make 10 black
immediately.
I'll make seven red.
That's the change.
And that the rest is just a
rotation.
So, we have 18 over here.
I think I actually have to
rotate to keep some red
blackness here.
Eight comes between seven and
ten.
So it goes here.
11 goes between ten and 18,
so it goes here.
22 and 26 come after 18.
Now, if I'm lucky,
I should satisfy all of
properties that I want.
OK, now, if I'm lucky,
I should satisfy all the
properties that I want.
Every node is red or black.
Every black node has a child.
This is the last place we
change.
Red nodes have black children,
and all the black heights
should be well defined.
For every node,
the number of black nodes along
any node to leaf path is the
same.
And you check,
that was true before,
and I did a little bit of
trickery with the recoloring
here.
But it's still true.
I mean, you can check that just
locally around this rotation.
OK, we'll do that in a little
bit.
For now, it's just an example.
It's probably not terribly
clear where these re-colorings
and rotations come from
necessarily, but it worked,
and it at least convinces you
that it's possible.
And now, we'll give a general
algorithm for doing it.
Any questions before we go on?
So, it's not exactly,
I mean, just writing of the
algorithm is not terribly
intuitive.
Red black trees of the sort of
thing where you play around a
bit.
You say, OK,
I'm going to just think about
recoloring and rotations.
Let's restrict myself to those
operations.
What could I do?
Well, I'll try to recolor.
If that works great,
it pushes the problem up
higher.
And, there's only log n levels,
order log n levels,
so that's going to take order
log n time.
At some point,
I'll get stuck.
I can't recolor anymore.
Then it turns out,
a couple of rotations will do
it.
Always, two rotations will
suffice.
And you just play with it,
and that turns out to work.
And here's how.
OK, so let's suppose we have a
red black tree.
And value x,
we want to insert.
Here's the algorithm.
First, we insert it into the
BST.
So that we know.
Then, we color the node red.
And here, I'm going to use a
slightly more precise notation.
Color is a field of x.
And now, we are going to walk
our way up the tree with a while
loop until we get to the root,
or until we reach a black node.
So, in general,
x initially is going to be the
element that we inserted.
But, we're going to move x up
the tree.
If ever we find that x is a
black node, we're happy because
maybe its parent is red.
Maybe it isn't.
I don't care.
Black nodes can have
arbitrarily colored parents.
It's red nodes that we worry
about.
So, if x is red,
we have to keep doing this
loop.
Of course, I just wrote the
wrong one.
While the color is red,
we're going to keep doing this.
So, there are three cases,
or six, depending on how you
count.
That's what makes this a little
bit tricky to memorize.
OK, but there are some
symmetric situations.
Let me draw them.
What we care about,
I've argued,
is between x and its
grandparent.
So, I'm using p of x here to
denote parent of x just because
it's shorter.
So, p of x is x's grandparent.
Left of p of x is the left
child.
So, what I'm interested in is I
look at x.
And, if I don't assign any
directions, x is the child of
some p of x, and p of x is the
child of the grandparent,
p of p of x.
Now, these edges aren't
vertical.
They are either left or right.
And, I care about which one.
In particular,
I'm looking at whether the
parent is the left child of the
grandparent.
So, I want to know,
does it look like this?
OK, and I don't know whether x
is to the left or to the right
of the parent.
But, is parent of x the left
child of p of x,
or is it the right child?
And these two cases are totally
symmetric.
But I need to assume it's one
way or the other.
Otherwise, I can't draw the
pictures.
OK, so this will be,
let's call it category A.
And, this is category B.
And, I'm going to tell you what
to do in category A.
And category B is symmetric.
You just flip left and right.
OK, so this is A.
So, within category A,
there are three cases.
And within category B,
there is the same three cases,
just reversed.
So, we're going to do is look
at the other child of the
grandparent.
This is one reason why we sort
of need to know which way we are
looking.
If the parent of x is the left
child of the grandparent,
we're going to look at the
other child of the grandparent,
which would be the right child
of the grandparent,
call that node y.
This is also known as the uncle
or the aunt of x,
depending on whether y is male
or female.
OK, so this is uncle or aunt.
Unfortunately,
in English, there is no
gender-free version of this as
far as I know.
There's parent and child,
but no uncle-aunt.
I'm sure we could come up with
one.
I'm not going to try.
It's going to sound bad.
OK, so why do I care about y?
Because, I want to see if I can
do this recoloring step.
The recoloring idea was,
well, the grandparents,
let's say it's black.
If I can push the blackness of
the grandparent down into the
two children,
then if both of these are red,
in other words,
then I'd be happy.
Then I'd push the problem up.
This guy is now red.
This guy is black.
So these two are all right.
This one may violate the great
grandparent.
But we will just keep going up,
and that will be fine.
Today, if we're lucky,
y is red.
Then we can just do recoloring.
So, if the color of y is red,
then we will recolor.
And, I'm going to defer this to
a picture called case one.
OK, let me first tell you how
the cases breakup,
and then we will see how they
work.
So, if we're not in case one,
so this L should be aligned
with that, then,
then we are either in case two
or three.
So, here's the dichotomy.
It turns out we've actually
seen all of the cases,
maybe not A versus B,
but we've seen the case of the
very beginning where we just
recolor.
That's case one.
The next thing we saw is,
well, it's kind of annoying
that the grandparent and ten,
so seven and ten were not
straight.
They were zigzagged.
So, case two is when they are
zigzagged.
It turns out if x is the right
child of its parent,
and the parent is the left
child of the grandparent,
that's a we've assumed so far,
that is case two.
OK, the other case is that x is
the left child of its parent.
So, then we have a left chain,
x, parent of x,
grandparent of x.
That is case three.
OK, I did not write else here
because what case two does is it
reduces to case three.
So, in case two,
we are going to do the stuff
that's here.
And then, we're going to do the
stuff here.
For case three,
we just do the stuff here.
Or in case one,
And then, that finishes the
three cases on the A side,
then back to this if.
We say else,
this is case B,
which is the same as A,
but reversing the notions of
left and right,
OK, in the natural way.
Every time we write left of
something, we instead write
right of something,
and vice versa.
So, this is really just
flipping everything over.
We'll just focus on category A.
And, let's see what we do in
each of the three cases.
We've seen it in an example.
But let's do it generically.
Let's do it here.
Sorry, there's one more line to
the algorithm,
I should say.
It's not aligned with here.
We color the root.
There's a chance when you do
all of this that the root
becomes red.
We always want the root to be
black.
If it's red,
we set it to black at the very
end of the algorithm.
This does not change the black
height property.
Everything will still be fine
because every path either goes
to the root or it doesn't,
every x to leaf path.
So, changing the root from red
to black is no problem.
It will increase the black
heights of everyone,
but all the paths will still
have the same value.
It will be one larger.
So, let's look at the three
cases.
And, I'm going to use some
notation.
Remember, we had triangles in
order to denote arbitrary
subtrees when we define a
rotation.
I'm going to use triangle with
a dot on top to say that this
subtree has a black root.
So, when I fill something
white, it means black because
I'm on a black board.
Sorry.
OK, and I also have the
property that each of these
triangles have the same black
height.
So, this will let me make sure
that the black height property,
property four,
is being observed.
So, let me just show you case
one.
We always want to make sure
property four is preserved
because it's really hard to get
that back.
It's essentially the balance of
the tree.
So, let's suppose we have some
node, C, left child,
A, right child,
B, and some subtrees hanging
off of those guys.
And, all of those subtrees have
the same black height.
So, in other words,
these things are all at the
same level.
OK, this is not quite what I
wanted, sorry.
So, I'm considering,
this is node x.
x is red, and its parent is
red.
Therefore, we need to fix
something.
We look at the node,
y, which is over here.
And, I'll call it,
the key is D.
The node is called y.
OK, it has subtrees hanging off
as well, all with the same black
height.
So, that will be true.
If all of these nodes are red,
then all of these nodes have
the same black height.
And therefore,
all of the child subtrees,
which have black roots,
all had to have the same black
height as well.
OK, so we're looking at a big
chunk of red children subtree of
a black node,
looking at all the stuff that
happens to be red.
In case one,
why is red so it participates?
So, a way to think of this as
if we converted into the
two-three-four-tree,
or tried to,
we would merge all of this
stuff into one node.
That's essentially what we're
doing here.
This is not a two-three-four
tree, though.
We now have five children,
which is bad.
This is why we want to fix it.
So, we're going to recolor in
case one.
And, we're going to take C.
Instead of making C black,
and A and D red,
we are going to make A and D
black, and C red.
So, C is red.
A is black.
D is black.
And, the subtrees are the same.
B is the same.
It's still red.
OK, now we need to check that
we preserve property four,
that all of the paths have the
same number of black nodes.
That follows because we know we
didn't touch these subtrees.
They all have the same black
height.
And, if you look at any path,
like, all the paths from A are
going to have that black height.
All the paths from C are going
to have that black height plus
one because there's a black node
in all the left paths,
and there is a black node in
all the right paths.
So, all the black links are the
same.
So, this preserves property
four.
And, it fixes property three
locally because B used to
violate A.
Now B does not violate
anything.
C, now, might be violated.
So, what we're going to do is
set x, our new value of x,
will be C.
So, it used to be B.
We move it up a couple levels.
Or, in the original tree,
yeah, we also move it up a
couple levels.
So, we're making progress up
the tree.
And then we continue this loop.
That's case one:
recolor, go up.
C may violate its parent in
which case we have to recurse.
So, we are recursing,
in some sense,
or continuing on C.
So now, let's look at case two.
So, I'm still,
in some sense,
defining this algorithm by
picture.
This is some nice,
graphical, programming
language.
So, let's draw case two.
Yeah, I forgot to mention
something about case one.
So, I drew some things here.
What do I actually know is
true?
So, let's look at the algorithm
in which I've now reversed.
But, we are assuming that we
are in category A.
In other words,
the parent is the left child of
the grandparent.
So, A is the left child of C.
That much I knew.
Therefore, y is the right
child.
D is the right child of C.
I didn't actually know whether
B was the right child or the
left child.
It didn't matter.
In case one,
it doesn't matter.
OK, so I should've said,
the children of A may be
reversed.
But it just said the same
picture.
OK, I thought of this because
in case two, we care.
So, case one:
we didn't really care.
In case two,
we say, well,
case two is up there,
is x the right child of the
parent, or the left child?
If it's the right child,
we are in case two.
So now, I can really know that
x here, which is B,
is the right child of A.
Before, I didn't know and I
didn't care.
Now, I'm assuming that it's
this way.
OK, y is still over here.
And now, now we know that y is
black.
So, y over here is a black
node.
So now, if I did the
contraction trick,
all of these nodes,
A, B, and C,
would conglomerate into one.
I only have four children.
That actually looks pretty
good.
y would not be involved because
it's black.
So, in this case,
we are going to do a left
rotation on A.
So, we take the edge,
we turn at 90∞.
What we get is A on the left,
B on the right still.
It should preserve the in order
traversal, C up top still.
We have the y subtree hanging
off, as before.
We have one of the other three
subtrees hanging off B,
and the other two now hang off
A.
So, this is just a generic
rotation picture applied to this
edge.
OK, what that does,
is before we had a zigzag
between x and its grandparent.
Now, we have a zigzig.
We have a straight path between
x.
So, x is still down here.
I'm not changing x in this case
because after I do case two,
I immediately do case three.
So, this is what case three
will look like.
And now, I continue on to case
three.
So, finally,
here's case three.
And, this will finally complete
the insertion algorithm.
We have a black node,
C.
We have a red left child from
We have a red,
left, grandchild which is x.
And then, we have these black
subtrees all of the same black
height hanging off,
OK, which is exactly what we
had at the end of case two.
So, that definitely connects
over.
And remember,
this is the only case left in
category A.
Category A, we assumed that B
was the parent of x,
was the left child of the
grandparent, B or C.
So, we know that.
We already did the case one,
y over here as red.
That was case one.
So, we are assuming y is black.
Now, we look at whether x was
the left child or the right
child.
If it was the right child,
we made it into the left child.
x actually did change here.
Before, x was B.
Now, x is A.
OK, and then case three,
finally, is when x is the left
child of the parent who is the
left child of the grandparent.
This is the last case we have
to worry about.
And, what we do is another
rotation just like the last
rotation we did in the example.
That was case three.
So, we're going to do a right
rotate in this case of C.
And, we are going to recolor.
OK, so, what do we get?
Well, B now becomes the root.
And, I'm going to make it
black.
OK, remember,
this is the root of the
subtree.
There is other stuff hanging
off here.
I really should have drawn
extra parents in all of these
pictures.
There was somewhere in the
middle of the tree.
I don't know where.
It could be a rightward branch;
it could be a leftward branch.
We don't know.
C becomes the child of B,
and I'm going to make it a red
child.
A becomes a child of B,
as it was before,
keep it red.
And, everything else just hangs
off.
So, there were four subtrees
all at the same black height.
And, in particular,
this last one had y,
but we don't particularly care
about y anymore.
Now, we are in really good
shape because we should have no
more violations.
Before, we had a violation
between x and its parent,
A and B.
Well, A and B still have a
parent child relation.
But B is now black.
And, B is black,
so we don't care what its
parent looks like.
It could be red or black.
Both are fine.
We are no longer violating
property three.
We should be done in this case.
Property three is now true.
If you want,
you can say,
well, x becomes this node.
And then, the loop says,
oh, x is no longer red.
Therefore, I'm done.
We also need to check that
property four is preserved
during this process.
Again, it's not hard because of
the two-three-four tree
transformation.
If I contract all the red
things into their parents,
everything else has a constant,
I mean, every path in that tree
has the same length because they
have the same black length.
And over here,
that will still be true.
It's a little bit trickier
here, because we are recoloring
at the same time.
But, if you look at a path that
comes through this tree,
it used to go through a black
node, C, and then maybe some red
stuff; I don't care.
And then, it went through these
trees, which all have the same
black height.
So they were all the same.
Now, you comment,
and you go through a black node
called B.
And then, you go through some
red nodes.
It doesn't really matter.
But all the trees that you go
through down here have the same
black height.
So, every path through this
tree will have the same black
length, OK, if it starts from
the same node.
So, we preserve property four.
We fix property three.
That is the insertion
algorithm.
It's pretty long.
This is something you'll
probably just have to memorize.
If you try a few examples,
it's not so hard.
We can see that all the things
we did in this example were the
three cases.
The first step,
which unfortunately I had to
erase for space,
all we did was recolor.
We recolored ten,
and eight, and 11.
That was a case one.
Ten was the grandparent of 15.
Then, we looked at ten.
Ten was the violator.
It was a zigzag case relative
to its grandparent.
So, we did a right rotation to
fix that, took this edge,
and turned it so that ten
became next to seven.
That's the picture on the top.
Then, 18, which is the new
violator, with its grandparent,
is a zigzig.
They are both going in the same
direction.
And, now, we do one more
rotation to fix that.
That's really the only thing
you have to remember.
Recolor your grandparent if you
can.
Otherwise, make it zigzig.
And then, do one last rotation.
And recolor.
And that will work.
I mean, if you remember that,
you will figure out the rest on
any particular example.
We rotate ten over.
That better be black,
because in this case it's
becoming the root.
But, we will make it black no
matter what happens because
there has to be one black node
there.
If we didn't recolor at the
same time, we would violate
property four.
Why don't I draw that just for,
OK, because I have a couple
minutes.
So, if we just did the rotation
here, so let's say,
not the following,
we take B.
B is red.
This will give some intuition
as to why the algorithm is this
way, and not some other way.
And, C is black.
That's what we would have
gotten if we just rotated this
tree, rotated B,
or rotated C to the right.
So, these subtrees hang off in
the same way.
Subtrees look great because
they all have the same black
height.
But, you see,
there's a problem.
If we look at all the paths
starting from B and going down
to a leaf, on the left,
the number of black nodes is
whatever the black height is
over here.
Label that: black height,
whereas all the paths on the
right will be that black height
plus one because C is black.
So now, we've violated property
four.
So, we don't do this in case
three.
After we do the rotation,
we also do a recoloring.
So, we get this.
In other words,
we are putting the black node
at the top because then every
path has to go through that
node, whereas over here,
some of the nodes went through
the C.
Some of them went through A.
So, this is bad.
Also, we would have violated
property three.
But, the really bad thing is
that we are violating property
four over here.
OK, let me sum up a little bit.
So, we've seen,
if we insert into a red black
tree, we can keep it a red black
tree.
So, RB insert adds x to the set
to the dynamic set that we are
trying to maintain,
and preserves red blackness.
So, it keeps the tree a red
black tree, which is good
because we know then it keeps
logarithmic height.
Therefore, all queries in red
black trees will keep taking
logarithmic time.
How long does red black insert
take?
We know we are aiming for log n
time preparation.
We are not going to prove that
formally, but it should be
pretty intuitive.
So, cases two and three,
sorry, pointing at the wrong
place, cases two and three are
terminal.
When we do case three,
we are done.
When we do case two,
we are about to do case three,
and then we are done.
OK, so the only thing we really
have to count is case one
because each of these
operations, they are recoloring,
rotation, they all take
constant time.
So, it's a matter of,
how many are there?
Case one does some recoloring,
doesn't change the tree at all,
and moves x up by two levels.
We know that the height of the
tree is, at most,
two log n plus one.
So, the number of case ones is,
at most, log n plus one.
OK, so the number of case ones
is, at most, log n.
So, those take log n time.
And then, the number of case
twos and threes is,
at most, one for one of these
columns.
Well, together,
twos and threes is,
at most, two.
OK, so, log n time,
cool.
The other thing that is
interesting about red black
insertion is that it only makes
order one rotations.
So, most of the changes are
recolorings.
Case one just does recoloring,
no rotations.
Case two maybe does one
rotation.
Case three does one rotation if
you happen to be in those cases.
So, the number of rotations is,
at most, two.
It's either one or two in an
insertion.
It's kind of nice because
rotating a tree is a bit more
annoying than recoloring a tree.
Why?
Because if you had,
say, a data structure,
you have a search tree,
presumably, people are using
the search tree for something.
They are, like,
making queries.
For example,
the search tree represents all
the documents matching the word
computer in Google.
You've got the Google T-shirt
on here, so let's use a Google
reference.
You have the search tree.
It stores all the things
containing the word Google.
You'd like to search may be for
the ones that were modified
after a certain date,
or whatever it is you want to
do.
So, you're doing some queries
on this tree.
And, people are pummeling
Google like crazy with queries.
They get a zillion a second.
Don't quote me on that.
The number may not be accurate.
It's a zillion.
But, people are making searches
all the time.
If you recolor the tree,
people can still make searches.
It's just a little bit you are
flipping.
I don't care in a search
whether a node is red or black
because I know it will have
logarithmic height.
So, you can come along and make
your occasional updates as your
crawler surfs the Web and finds
changes.
And, recoloring is great.
Rotation is a bit expensive
because you have to lock those
nodes, make sure no one touches
them for the duration that you
rotate them, and then unlock
them.
So, it's nice that the number
of rotations is small,
really small,
just two, whereas the time has
to be log n because we are
inserting into a sorted list
essentially.
So, there is an n log n lower
bound if we do n insertions.
OK, deletion and I'm not going
to cover here.
You should read it in the book.
It's a little bit more
complicated, but the same ideas.
It gets the same bounds:
log n time order one rotations.
So, check it out.
That's red black trees.
Now, you can maintain data in
log n time preparation:
cool.
We'll now see three ways to do
it.